sadly this afternoon i must cancel sarah
ramirez she is evidently an actress
uh best known for her role on grey's
anatomy the reason i have to cancel
sarah today is because of a recent post
on instagram where she
came out as non-binary now you might ask
what does coming out as non-binary mean
the answer is that it doesn't mean
anything because non-binary is not a
thing unfortunately
um there is a binary and it's not
possible to not be a part of it
the binary broadly speaking breaks down
like this
okay in one camp
you have people who can get pregnant
in the other camp you have people who
can get the people in the first camp
pregnant
pregnant impregnator you might say not
the most eloquent way of putting it but
that's what it is
and there's your binary okay you can
call people in these camps whatever you
want call them team a and team b
you can make up some names like i don't
know snaggle spiffs and gallywags
sounds a little bit like harry potter
characters but whatever or you know you
could even
use names like i don't know women and
men um the name doesn't matter it's the
function
and the biology that matters yes i can
already hear your objection
you are you are right now shouting i
know you're saying what about women who
can't get pregnant huh
bet you never thought of them checkmate
loser
and then you take a sip of your kombucha
confident that you've just debunked
biology by pointing out that infertile
women exist but you haven't i assure you
infertile women
don't invalidate the statement that
women can get pregnant any more than a
man who loses an arm in a wood chipper
accident invalidates the statement that
humans have two arms
his accident doesn't mean that humans
don't have two arms or that we must now
entertain the possibility that there
might be humans out there with eight
arms and 12 legs and 46 heads
it just means he's supposed to have two
arms
but the wood chipper had other ideas
okay
in a similar way infertile women
are that way either because they're
older and their time of fertility has
passed or
because something went wrong illness
mutation deformity injury surgery
some known thing interceded and deprived
this woman
of that function but we know that she's
supposed to have it
like the man with the one arm is
supposed to have two this is not a
problem for the binary on the contrary
this is what's known as an exception
that proves the rule
okay so that's the binary now
all of that said let's check in with
sarah ramirez reading from one of my
favorite news organizations lgbtq nation
uh it says sarah ramirez the actor who
played the bisexual character cali
torres on the medical drama tv series
grey's anatomy came out as non-binary in
an august 27
instagram post the post which showed
ramirez with a crop top haircut was
captioned
new profile pic in me is the capacity to
be girlish boy boyish girl
boyish boy girlish girl all neither
hashtag non-binary all right now hang on
first of all
it's just a haircut relax okay she she
got a haircut now she thinks she's a
shape-shifter this is like
it's like if i spiked my hair up and
went behold i am a transdimensional
being
unbound by the laws of gravity i am god
look upon me and weep ye mortals you see
my hair cut
you can't get superpowers for 19 bucks
at sports clips is all i'm trying to say
okay anyway back to the article says
ramirez previously came out as bisexual
in october 2016
while making um remarks at the true
colors united's 40 to none summit
wait so she came out twice can you do
that she's is that a well okay i guess
it's a two different thing non-binary
bisexual
uh back to the article is at the time
ramirez said
and because of the intersections that
exist in my own life woman multiracial
woman
woman of color queer bisexual mexican
irish
american immigrant and raised by
families heavily rooted in catholicism
on both my mexican and irish sides
i am deeply invested in projects that
allow our youths voices to be heard
and that support our youth in owning
their own complex narratives
so that we can show up for them in the
ways they need us to
uh and says ramirez who has been married
to her husband ryan de bolt since 2011
is a member of the true colors fun board
of directors and blah blah blah okay
uh first of all you you notice how her
the intersections she lists
are completely redundant she lists woman
three times
queer and bisexual is two different
things and multi-racial and women of
color has two separate things
and mexican and immigrant as two's
everything she's throwing 50-yard bombs
in garbage time basically she's padding
the stats
okay um this is a person desperate to be
seen
as interesting and different but like so
many people today she's convinced that
the only way to do that is to get
yourself into as many demographic
categories as possible
now if we were going to psychoanalyze
all of this
there are many directions we could go um
it would be a long and winding and
rather terrifying journey i suspect but
i want to focus on just this one thing
this this business about being
non-binary
as she says a boy a girl both and
neither
that of course makes no sense whatsoever
you cannot be something and be another
thing that's fundamentally different and
be both
and be none of them all at once you
might as well claim that you're standing
on the earth and the surface of the sun
at the same time
it is nonsensical objectively but
um what's going on here really though
you know
why do people make these claims about
themselves
i think the answer or part of the answer
is this
sarah ramirez isn't so much observing
something about herself she is rather
making assumptions about other people
okay
kind of like what michelle obama was
doing and i'll explain more what i mean
because it strikes me that when when
people do this especially when
celebrities
come out and say oh i am just so
complicated my inner life is so
interesting and unique
my experiences are so profound i cannot
be
defined by the labels that the rest of
you use no no i
i am so many things and yet none of
those things i am like a work of
abstract art i am a walking poem
a song in the wind is my existence and
they go on and on and on
um and then they actually explain in
more detail what they mean
and why they have come to this
conclusion that they belong to a whole
new category of human existence
non-binary or whatever other label they
want when you listen to their
description of their inner experience
you think wait a second that's just
that's just being a person that's pretty
normal the categories and labels and
jargon are different and bizarre and
sound kind of crazy but the actual
experiences underneath it
that's not special at all these people
are extraordinarily narcissistic
you have to understand especially
celebrities and so
they have normal human emotions and
experiences and assume
that the average person must not
experience any of this themselves
that they must be going through
something that is just far beyond the
emotional and psychological reaches of
the plebe on the street
they you know they they must be and they
must be making this assumption otherwise
how would they know that the label of
woman doesn't accurately describe them
how do they know that all women don't
have the same sorts of emotions and
experiences they do how do they know
that what they're feeling isn't just
what women
women feel they assume that it's
different
and that assumption must be born at
least in part by extreme arrogance
so you're a woman with some
traditionally masculine interests and
tendencies
so what that's not special at all it
doesn't make you
not a woman that just makes you a woman
that's part of being a woman a person a
human
we don't need a new category for you it
doesn't make you a woman and a man and
none and all together
the most feminine women women in the
world have masculine aspects of their
personality
my wife for instance very feminine very
good at traditionally feminine things
like decorating for example but
if you pour her three fingers of 100
proof whiskey she'll guzzle that thing
straight
no problem she built her own barn for
the chickens i
i helped in fairness but still she knows
how to bait a hook you know
i could go on does that mean that she's
not a woman
she's non-binary she's a man a woman
both and neither no
she's just a woman but but she's a woman
with some unique and interesting
traits and facets to her personality
indeed
what makes the thing about the whiskey
kind of funny and cool is precisely that
she's a woman
you know i can hold my liquor too but
nobody cares about that i'm a man that's
expected
what allows it to be different what
allows us to be different and develop
our own identity and personality are the
ways that we put
our own spin on the categories we
naturally belong to
in the same way we all belong to the
category of human being right
and because of that if any one of us
ever figures out how to fly without
mechanical assistance
that's going to be a pretty big deal if
we were birds it wouldn't be
and if you do ever start flying that
wouldn't make you a bird if it did
then this utterly fascinating
gobsmacking thing about you would
suddenly be
rote and routine again what makes us
interesting are the variations within
the categories
if you deny the categories or experience
variation and decide that it means that
you belong to the other category you
know you're a man who has feminine
tendencies in certain areas so you
decide that you are in fact a woman
if you do that then you actually lose
what made you interesting
you lose your uniqueness
gender is binary because of biology as i
explained at the beginning nothing you
can ever do
or feel will change that you are a man
or a woman a he or her you are not both
you are not one than the other you are
not neither you are not a they
um and it takes i suppose some measure
of basic humility to admit that and
submit yourself to that reality
which imposes itself on you whether you
like it or not anyway
but that doesn't mean you have to live a
cookie cutter existence
or think and act just like everybody
else on your side of the binary
if you're a woman be whatever kind of
woman you want
wear whatever you want get whatever sort
of haircut you want
the high top fade on a woman doesn't do
much for me personally but hey it's your
head do what you want
live how you want think what you want
that's not to say that every choice we
make is going to be equally good healthy
and moral but the point is
simply that you have a lot of freedom as
a woman to be the sort of woman you want
to be
you just don't have the freedom to be
not a woman
and that's okay in fact there's a lot of
freedom in accepting that
but for now sarah ramirez does belong to
a new category of existence
an ever-growing category that will be
the category of cancelled
by me hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated